hi my name is Felina hermans I'm
assistant professor at Del University of
Technology and I'm here today to talk
about spreadsheets so you might think
why are we talking about spreadsheets at
a developers conference well
spreadsheets are very often mislabeled
people think of spreadsheets as being
data but they are really wrong
spreadsheets are actually go I go all
around the world to spread the happy
word the gospel of my life
and tell people that spreadsheets are
Cod so please if you remember only one
thing of this entire talk please let it
be that spreadsheets are
go you might not believe me that's okay
I have three reasons for you why
spreadsheets are actually should be
considered as pieces of programming
first of all they're used for very
similar problems here you have an
investment calculator you put some data
in something is being calculated and you
get some output you could do this with
any programming language you could do it
in Java or in C or in pure script I just
learned that about that today really
cool but you could also do it in a
spreadsheet a typical data calculation
problem you could use a spreadsheet for
that obviously you could ask yourself
the question why would I do this in a
spreadsheet why do people do this in a
spreadsheet and not in a proper language
well I can tell you why people do this
in spreadsheets is because we as
developers we are bad at making software
those people the guy that built it I
I've asked people like that you know why
do you do it in a spreadsheet why didn't
you ask it to build something for you
and he said yes we did that and they
said it was going to be 3 million and 6
months and it was 10 million and N9
months and it had half the features we
wanted so from that perspective
spreadsheets look really easy and cheap
you have it already on your machine you
think hey I can do it myself people
perceive themselves sometimes as being
better better developers than we are so
reason one used for very similar
problems so I go to Great Lengths to
make my point to Such Great Lengths in
fact that I have implemented a touring
machine in spreadsheet formulas to show
that spreadsheet formulas are actually
touring
complete so here you see it one row of
the spreadsheet is one iteration of the
Lin and you actually see the Hat moving
over the lint I think it's a very cool
visualization of a cheering machine as
well as being proof that spreadsheet
formulas are chewing
complete reason tree spreadsheets suffer
from very typical software
problems they suffer from very typical
software problems for instance they
often lack a manual like software they
stay alive for a very long time and
during their lifespan they're used by
many different people so all in all I
think we can conclude that spreadsheets
are code they suffer from the same
problems they are just as complex and
they use for very similar
problems I'm going to go a little bit
further than that I'm not just going to
argue that spreadsheets are a
programming language I'm going to argue
that spreadsheet Lang spreadsheets are
the next language that you should learn
resistance is
futile and again you may not believe me
I have a few reasons why you should
learn spreadsheet as your next
programming
language first of all they are live
programming you know Brett Victor is
going around making making Fame on the
internet saying oh we need life
programming we need to have code on the
one hand side and the Run running of the
code at the same time we have that since
visal I mean the spreadsheet is live
programming of alra you put in a formula
and you immediately get the result no
compiling needed so it's Life
program second reason that you should
learn spreadsheet do you like pure
functional languages you know you we all
love hasal forget about
hasal spreadsheet formulas are pure the
only thing a formula can do is take
input from other cells and do a
calculation based on it no side effects
are possible it's impossible from a
spreadsheet formula to do anything else
but present the result they are pure a
pure functional
language third reason you should learn
spreadsheet is they are the linga franka
of computing everyone knows spreadsheets
know your next door neighbor is managing
his fantasy football team in a
spreadsheet your accountant like the
boring most boring guy on Earth he knows
how to do spreadsheets everyone knows
this but us developers that's crazy
we should know what everyone else is
programming so I'm going to assume for a
minute that you are convinced that you
should learn Pro spreadsheet programming
and since you're here in the room anyway
let's do a little spreadsheet
programming I'm going to implement
selection sorts in spreadsheet formulas
to show you the real power of
spreadsheets so selection sort I'm going
to assume you're familiar with it you
sort a list by picking the minimum and
putting it at the front of the row and
you do that repeatedly and your list of
integers is sorted so how do we do this
in a spreadsheet I have a list of
numbers here I'm just going to at the
rank the index of the number for
convenience so the first thing obviously
we need to do is take the minimum
spreadsheets excel in this case we have
a nice function called the minimum super
easy Min with the as an argument our a
list by the way what you could also do
I'm not going to use that but this is
little known uh syntax is you can also
use an entire row so we could also pick
the minimum of the entire
row just as you can also take take the
minimum of a colon a that's a little bit
more known syntax we're going to use
this later on so I'm just going to show
you you can also take the minimum of one
row what we need next obviously is the
index of the minimum the position where
the minimum is in the list and we can
use a match function for that and what a
match function does it's going to look
at this thing the one and going to
return the location within the list so
we get 10 that's correct because our
minute is on index
10 so we're going to start small because
you're not doing this every day so we
going to make a not sort immediately but
we're going to start with a simple
formula this formula is just going to
Mark places where we are going to swap
later with an X and an underscore for
all the places where we're not going to
swap so we can gradually build up the
formula so it's easier to get all the
steps so the first part of us our
formula is if our index is equal to the
index that the minimum is on then we're
going to swap and otherwise we just
place an underscore and this is still
quite easy we can drag this long but
something is wrong there's no X there
does anyone know what I have forgotten
here yes the uh dollar sign yes exactly
the dollar sign so if you drag a formula
along Excel automatically updates all
the references unless you put a dollar
sign in there so now you see here we've
dragged it but it's actually referring
to this one and that guy instead of this
one so if we put a dollar here and drag
it again then you see we get an x on the
swapping sign and we're going to we know
that we're going to drag everything down
later on so let's just put a dollar here
because we know that we're we're going
to use the index
row so obviously we need the other thing
to swap with which is the index of the
swap we start at the first index and
then we're gradually moving along the
row that we're going to sort and then we
need to do sort of a reverse look up
what we need to do now is look up what
value goes with the swap function and we
can do that in Excel with an index
function might be a little bit Contra
inuitive because in some programming
languages the max is the index but it's
as it is the index and what it does is
it's going to return from this block
that row and the column you put into it
so the first row it is just one row and
this column so we get 13 and we can
update now our function because we can
add the different the other Branch we
had the branch for swapping the one
value now we can add the branch for
swapping if we are our index is equal to
the swap index we are also going to
switch
values so we have now correctly marked
the two places where we're going to
swap let's now pick the easiest thing to
fill in what are we going to do in the
position of the underscore well that's
sort of easy if we're not swapping we're
just going to pick the value right above
us super easy so now we have done
everything all the things that don't
have to change they're not changed in
the next line but we are going to change
the swaps let's do something first let's
add a little bit of conditional
formatting to make it easier for us to
see what's going on so I'm going to make
the swap spots yellow and green so I can
easily see what is going on and this is
very similar to what I did in a touring
machine also with conditional formatting
I made the head of the lint very easy
so we're going to change this what do we
have to do if our index of the minimum
is equal to the index of the swap what
do we have to Output
then the thing you want to swap the
thing you want to swap correctly the
minimum and in the in the other case if
our index is equal to the index of swap
then we're going to Output the minimum
easy peasy HH there we have it we have
swapped two values super easy easy so
we're almost done we can just drag this
down and then we do this just until the
list is sorted H fortunately something
is wrong it's almost correct and you see
how the condition of formatting helps us
to understand and it's like a debugger
for spreadsheets the conditional
forting who knows what I
forgot has anyone seen my
mistake yes need to
ruce yeah so now taking the minimum of
the entire list so obviously I continue
to find the one and swap out that one so
you see the minimum is the minimum is
one everywhere so Excel has you covered
we have a function for that called the
offset and what offset does is you put
in a range and then you move that range
over the spreadsheet rows and columns so
you can move we can move our minimum
we're going to move it zero um rows and
B B4 minus one column so the first time
we're not moving it at all and then in
the next row we're moving it one two 3
four and then you can see every time
we're picking the minimum of the correct
row so let's see what happens if we
update a isn't that wonderful we have
done selection sort in a
stretchy but we're not there yet because
I know if I would stop now you would say
yeah but that's not programming with all
the E2 and B4 that's not how we normally
program we want to have a more beautiful
version so let's do that level two a
little bit scary you you have all seen
Marcos and lisp so I'm sure you can deal
with some scary stuff in the
spreadsheet so first funky syntax
feature does anyone know what this
formula means so it's a range and then a
space and then another range this is
correct syntax I didn't know that I only
know this because I built a parure of
spreadsheet formulas and I put in
millions and millions of spreadsheets
and then I hit this I what does it even
do what and then I input it into a
spreadsheet and I said that's cool so
anyone know what this
means you're next door neighbor does
you're
a come on guys no okay I'll help you a
little
bit it's the intersection of these two
ranges so the output of this formula is
the intersection of two ranges so in
this case it will be three and I can use
this n trick to make my formula a little
bit
cooler let's give things some names and
that's what programmers like so let's
say the row of all the indexes I just
call that index and then I can use that
to change my formula so here I was
directly pointing at E2 with the spaces
trick I can now change my function into
the intersection of the index and the E
column so this is my column and this is
the index so now I don't have to point
at it anymore E2 I can just say give me
wherever my column is intersecting
intersecting with index and the cool
thing about this syntax is that the
space the column I'm in is not mandatory
so you can remove it you can just drop
it and the the function will be exactly
the same so what this still means is
give me the value wherever I am
intersecting with index so that makes it
a little bit nicer and I can repeat this
trick a few times so let's say this is
Swap this is the index of swap this is
min and this is index Min this is how
I'm going to call those Nam ranges and I
can change this into this isn't that
nice it's almost like like like like
reading a book reading a novel if the
index is min then swap if the index swap
then Min awesome there's just one thing
of course that I really hate it's this
guy E3 needs to go it needs to disappear
here but I can't use an easy trick like
I did with the indexes with the named
ranges because every time I drag my
formula down it will change so I have to
go even scarier so let's dive a little
bit deeper into named ranges because so
far we have just been using named ranges
as you probably already knew them you
give a name to a value to a cell I mean
you point at a cell and you say this is
me this is swap so you put a formula or
you put a cell reference in here but you
can put other things in that field you
can give names ranges there's still
called named ranges but it don't have to
be named ranges what you could for
instance put in there all you need is
love you can put a constant in there and
now the name range all you need will
result in the value love isn't that nice
All You Need Is Love love is all you
need isn't that
fantastic but you can put in scar things
in your names ranges than just constants
there were other thinkers by the way
besides the Beatles who have also
thought about what exactly the essence
of Love is here's a guy I particularly
like however much I love you you will
always love me more well I can do that
in a name
change my love is 15 and so this is
still the same my love your love we can
just put in a constant 15 but what I can
do now is I can make a second name
change your love depending on the first
named range so I can say 1.3 times my
love so I've put a formula into a named
range instead of a constant instead of a
cell reference I put in a formula and
this actually works so you just get you
put in your love and then it's
19.5 so you use the name strange but
actually something is calculated in the
back we can go crazier than that here's
another thing we can express in
spreadsheets every day I love you
more so little formula my love is 15
what do I have to do now obviously I
have to make something to point to the
cell above because I want to use the
value of the cell above as an input for
my name trange so what can I do I can
use the row function normally you put in
a Cell there so you can do the row of A8
results in eight but what you can also
do is use it without arguments and then
it just Returns the row I am in right
now it's sort of this row if you
may I can use that in my name change
because I can say yesterday's love so
the love I'm going to use right above me
is on the location of my row minus one
and my column so now I have here it this
outputs just a string where I want to
point that so I'm almost there C4 and
this is the right location but instead
of the string of the cell reference I
need to have actually have the reference
there so there there's a thing in Excel
it's called the indirect it's very much
like an evil you put in a string and
what you get is the reference of that
string so this formula is exactly equal
to this formula indirect of a string is
exactly equal to that
reference I can use that so I can say
yesterday's love is the evil the
indirect of the cell of my row minus one
and my
column I can now use this value as an
input for my name range so I can say
okay today's love is what yesterday's
love times the vanan factor
1.004 and if I drag it down now I have a
formula in an in range that is dependent
on the cell above it so every time it
refers to the cell gets the value and
does the
calculation we can use that to get rid
of that that annoying E3 because I
didn't come here to talk about love I
came here to talk about selection s so
we can use Dynamic name ranges to get
rid of that annoying E3 we it has to go
so what we can do is we can make a
dynamic name change that is the previous
row just as we said yesterday's love the
previous row is the indirect of the row
above me and here I use that Min syntax
that I showed you all the way at the
beginning of my
one row you can use it to point that so
I just say the row above me and now it's
this isn't this nice just for comparison
I wrote also selection sword in Python
and you can see it's almost the same
actually I think my thing is a lot
concisor look at that who is winning now
python Isn't that
[Applause]
cool so of course now I'm going to talk
a little bit about my own research now
you are convinced that spreadsheets are
actually proper source code I can pitch
my own research here because if you are
going to argue that spreadsheets are
Source
codes then maybe we can apply some
software engineering methods to
spreadsheets this is exactly the idea of
my entire PhD teases that you can see
here I defended this last year and the
idea of my entire PhD teases is that if
you look at spreadsheets as code you can
actually help spreadsheet users to be
more like professional programmers
because obviously you know we're not
that good at making software but we have
tools for that we have a super smart IDE
that gives us autoc completion and
syntax highlighting that IDE is one of
the things that makes us better
programmers and we have integrated te
integrated build systems testing
spreadsheet users lack all those tools
so we can it's easy to make fun of them
because well they make errors in their
spreadsheets but yeah they don't really
have the tools so the idea of my
research is to transfer tools from
software engineering to spreadsheets to
help people understand their
spreadsheets better and to just be more
professional like software developers so
yeah the idea of my research is we can
help spreadsheet developers with
software engineering methods so one of
the things I've buil is called Bumblebee
and this is a refactoring tool for
spreadsheet formulas I'm going to show
you a little bit about how it looks now
so here you have it's a plugin in
Excel we have a typical formula that
some someone could have written in a
spreadsheet because he doesn't really
know spreadsheets so you have a sum
divided by a count but obviously it
would have been easier if you would use
the buildin average function there but
maybe you didn't know it maybe you were
in a hurry maybe this the formula has
evolved because first it was some and
then after that you thought oh I still
need to divide by count and it turn into
an average so our system knows that you
can ask bumblebe give me possible
rewrites on my formula and it says oh I
can do that I have found for you the sum
and count to average refactoring that
you can apply on this formula and if you
like it you can say yes apply it for me
it's applied and then H we rewrite your
formula to a better version an easier
version and you can apply it not only in
a range but also over an entire
worksheet or over an entire workbook
eradicate all the formulas that you
don't want to use anymore and replace
them by better
versions and we thought we can go a
little bit further than that we can help
users to Define their own refactorings
because we thought now spreadsheet
developers the power users they're
really good at writing formulas there
may be even writing a VB they should be
able to Define their own refactorings in
the spreadsheet so we made a little
language that you can see here where
users within their spreadsheet can
Define rewrite rules refactorings and
then they can subsequently apply those
refactorings within their spreadsheet so
you can say on every formula doesn't
matter what it is that's what the uh
square brackets means I can always round
it on a formula that looks like this
here's the sum and count that looks like
sum something divided by count something
I can transform that into to the average
we haven't really started testing this
part yet with users but we assume that
the users that are familiar with VB and
with complex formula should also be able
to write these type of
things so obviously if you say
refactoring you
say testing yeah you guys are still
awake if you say refracturing you say
testing if people are going to mess with
their spreadsheet or their source code
in an automatic way they want to know
that the thing is still functioning as
it was
before so initially we thought oh this
is going to be hard how are we going to
get professional spreadsheet users to
test it's already so hard to get
professional developers to test it's not
so easy it's hard to to get people
convinced of the idea that it's actually
worth it to write test they will it will
help you in in the end so I thought H
this is going to be hard but this was a
typical Ivory Tower approach where we
were thinking at the University instead
of looking what people were actually
doing because when we started looking at
spreadsheets we saw many spreadsheets
look like
this if the sum of these guys is not
aunds then I'm going to Output
error it's like a test right or like an
assertion the user of this spreadsheet
wanted to express that that block of
cells needed to be equal to 100
otherwise error something strange is
happening here so we thought we can use
these type of functions these type of
formulas that people are already writing
and we can leverage them to get people
to test better because it's easier to
reinforce behavior that people already
have than to try to convince them to
start to do something entirely different
so we build a tool called expector and
what that tool does another Excel plugin
is it can find those type of test
formulas and elaborate upon it so what
the tool it said hey I have detected a
test formula here and based on some
ristics that we use for the words like
okay and error and yes and no we even
saw a smiley face as the output of a
test we made a list of all the things
that people use as positive and negative
outcomes we can even say okay we think
in the case that it's not 100 it should
fail and otherwise it should pass and if
the user agrees with those tests you can
say Okay save them to my system as a
test
Suite and then you can use that because
then you don't need to look manually for
everything that says error or okay we
gather all the tests and everything that
has a passing outcome we make it green
and what we can do even is sort of do
test coverage show visually show users
the coverage of their tests by making
use of the fact that this formula refers
to those cells then I can say okay this
is a test and it's passing so I could
say that these guys are also tested
because they are covered by a test and
if something is wrong there at the end
it would have been tested by this guy
and we can do the same thing here we say
this is a Formula it it doesn't have a
test yet and it depends on these guys so
we say this is not tested and AR rest is
also not tested and this helps people to
sort of understand the robustness of the
spreadsheet understand what they have
tested yet and what parts of their
spreadsheet could still benefit from
some of those tests and one of the
followup things that we want to do we
haven't worked on that yet but that's
sort of our plan is to combine this with
complexity metrics of spreadsheet
formulas that we already worked on so we
can not only say this part of your
spreadsheet isn't tested yet but we
could also say this formula isn't tested
and this is the most complex one in your
spreadsheet so probably you want to
start with your test effort there
first so that's everything I wanted to
talk to you about today but before we go
to questions we have some time for that
I will summarize my entire talk in about
a minute so if you came in late or if
you were still processing the transend
fusure trends thingies from before this
is your second chance to get a hang of
my entire talk and obviously if you were
listening this is the optimal
preparation for question
asking so one thing please remember this
and tell all your friends spread sheets
are Cod this is what you absolutely need
to remember I am sure I have convinced
you of this fact with this
talk they are used for exact similar
purpose as many other programming
languages they are just as complex
because they are T in complete and they
suffer suffer from typical software
problems they are not just the
programming language they are the
coolest thing out there because they're
alive they are purely functional and
everyone already knows how to work with
them to show you how cool they are I
have implemented selection sword in a
sheet and it looks cooler than
python because spreadsheets are source
code you can use that idea to build upon
it and to make people's spreadsheet
lives better and for that I have built a
refracturing tool for spreadsheets and a
testing tool for spreadsheets if you
like my talk you can go to my website
where you can download those two plugins
Bumblebee and expector if you have Excel
2010 you can download them play with
them provide me with feedback if you
want to know more about my research I
run a research lab called the
spreadsheet lab where I for Force grad
student to also like this
stuff and if you want to connect feel
free to send me a tweet or send me an
email to get to know more about the
research that we're doing at Del
University of
Technology
[Applause]
questions ailable somewhere is yeah no
that not is it a real book I it's my
dissertation is that a real
book yeah it's by dissertation you can
download the PDF from my website but if
you would prefer a hard copy if you
email or tweet me your postal address
I'm happy to also send you a hard
copy do you have enough type information
to be able to T so say like oh we know
that this is a the data dependencies
let's generate all like lots of possible
values and finding that that are correct
so about the type the question was that
do you have enough type information to
generate test so there were other
researchers that worked on extracting
types from spreadsheets so I don't know
actually but now with your question I
think yeah you could maybe use the type
information that they are able to
extract from spreadsheets to generate
something but yeah the question would
obviously be are you going to look at
existing input that's already in the
spreadsheet or are you also going to
think about what other possible inputs
could be the case for every cell and how
would that like change the coverage or
something that would be
interesting you've made the great point
that spreadsheets are code but spreads
are also data yes and and spreadsheets
in general are a specific set of data so
what about the separation of the logic
like the code itself that you put in
here and the specific input set how do
you separate those out and say put the
logic under Source control and things
like that yeah so question was how would
you separate the logic from a
spreadsheet from the data in a
spreadsheet because that's that's it's
not just code it's also data so I showed
you the refactorings that I'm working on
they are now very low level exchanging
formulas but one of the things we want
to do in the future is to make
structural refactorings so you could
inde take an existing spreadsheet and
change the entire structure where you
would say I want all the logic in this
one sheet or this one place and all the
data in here and that would obviously be
a very nice first step towards migration
to something else or at least a clear
separation where you maybe protect all
the logic and only leave the input open
to the user so I would say a good
approach would be refactoring and then
more high level refracturing something
like extracts a
worksheet all the way at the back the
guy in the
purple
yeah so your question would be would it
be possible to to with color with a
color system indicate what parts are
input and what's calculation what output
yeah so obviously within many of the
tools that we do we have an an
understanding of the spreadsheet in
terms of what sells are input and what
are calculations so it wouldn't be that
hard in need to color code that in a
sense because we have we parse that
information anyway yes your experience
how standard
are how so your question is how
compatible are different spreadsheet
systems with each other how easy it is
to open
so that's a good question because for my
research basically I only looked at
looked at Excel because the type of
question uh the type of companies that
we worked with were large Banks large
investment companies they typically be
they would typically be Microsoft
companies so I would say if you if your
company depends on it I wouldn't depend
on those spreadsheet systems being
convertible to each other however for no
General use but it's hard to know
because yeah Excel is not entirely open
so there might be some strange behavior
that we don't exactly know how it's
implemented and we do know how that
works in Open Office so I wouldn't bet
my money on it I've actually deal that
oh
gole
Google terrible oh it's
terrible
develop spr
sheets everybody Google oh yeah of
course yes you spent this time sort of
teing us the name range and making
variable names and I think as
programmers we like making variable
names but we know that naming is
difficult and you've seen a lot of real
world
in your your
experience is the naming actually
worthwhile is it maybe this direct
manipulation maybe we shouldn't get rid
of the E3 that is perfectly tactile and
it's a good thing the TR so the question
is do name changes actually help there's
a girl she's called Rose mcdermit she
wrote her entire PhD Theses on the use
of named ranges in Excel and her her
main result was was that it's actually
not such a good
idea what does that mean so you can do
it but for so it's a little bit more
more nuanced than that for experienced
users it really helps so if you're an
experienced user and you put in names
then you will benefit from it but the
problem with named ranges that she found
was that if you hand over that
spreadsheet to someone who doesn't know
how the names work then it starts to be
really tricky because exactly as you see
well as you say you know E3 you can find
it but if you don't know how to find the
names it can be a little bit tricky in
the Excel interface because you can also
have the same name in different
worksheets and they might point to
different things so it's all good if you
if you know as with I would say as with
all difficult programming Concepts maybe
something like macros I would give the
same advice if you're an experienced
user and you know what you're doing it's
awesome but then someone else has to
maintain your code and then suddenly
it's not such a good idea anymore I
would say that would that holds for name
change as well they only you help if you
know how they work but unlike macros
naming things is very Elementary thing
with programming what does that result
say about programming right is it the
case that program with names too much
and we're used to it but such a good
idea yeah maybe maybe I mean I didn't
research that but I can Phil think about
it a little bit if you are um maybe it's
intuitive for us maybe we are used to
names but maybe for you know your your
normal average day guy that just wants
to get something to work is not that
necessary I could think that that would
be true I think one of the things is
cells already have names yeah and name
range is essentially like an alias think
oh is aliasing good oh maybe name yeah
that's an interesting way to put it yeah
you could say that E3 is a name in a
sense
you could say it's a pointer as well on
maybe you would think differ final
question so what what's exactly the
question
so it's true that Excel is super smart
if you copy paste formulas from here to
there then it will automatically update
update the references and most of the
times that what that is what you
want yeah
so yeah that's that's very true because
if you would have a name range here and
then you would drag so suppose you have
named all these cells you put a formula
here and you drag it down it doesn't
automatically refer to all the cells
that are next to it so in a sense by
adding the names you are interfering a
little bit with the things that Excel
can do based on the references but then
again on the other hand you if you see
the differences between those two
formulas and if you're looking at it six
months later maybe you would prefer to
invest a little bit more time in making
the spreadsheet and not relying on the
buildin logic so much because it will be
more maintainable if you come back to it
with the names so that might be a
tradeoff between investing investing
your time in more readable code now or
getting something quick now and then
being sorry later okay one more then or
two more
yes no I have not explored dynamic
programming would be interesting though
because you would say that the layout of
the spreadsheet would be nice to
visualize that could be my next strange
Lo talk thanks for the SU
yeser kind of
Sociology
spreadsheets programing like cousin but
you know you should look at the burdens
of a Feather unsession announ from last
night I'll have you know that Excel is
on the list
languages oh cool so you're already
considering it's a real programming
language yes
awesome well thank you if you want to
know more please get in touch in our
s